hallo mein name ist luca herzlich
willkommen zu einem neuen video ich habe
mir gedacht wir spielen heute mit turbo
diesmal und da geht es darum dass ich
diese hat typ da bin ich befinde mich
hier in diesem auto das ist nämlich dass
luca
er malt finds auch super cool wie er
sein lenkrad daran fast nämlich gar
nicht und wir können uns hier eigene
strecken bauen und dann schauen wie das
ganze funktioniert ich kann es einfach
anklicken und er wird jetzt mit volker
racho losfahren und ihr werdet sehen
dass ich ein dass
wir haben es geschafft wir können ja
auch noch verschiedene posen
oh mein gott diese pose hier hinten
haben wir noch wie wir da hinten dran
kleben dann haben wir noch wie wir daran
hängen dann auf ich kann mich bei diesem
2 60 konzentrieren er fährt los und
das war erfolgreich
das kaputtgeht haben ich habe als
vehikel nun einen schreibtischstuhl
genommen ist auch eine sehr bequeme
position wir können bei den kameras
jetzt noch wechseln zu free fly
character weg das ist die first person
kamera ich mache jetzt einfach mal dass
der automatisch lenkt und als discount
fangen wir jetzt mal so an und
das war super dieses replays und fassbar
wir auf dem boden so episch das hier ist
das nächste level was wir haben und zwar
sind wir ein wenig besser die sein dass
sie bereits schicken tatsächlich ich hab
jetzt hunger ich glaube dass jetzt
einfach eine strecke wo man gegen autos
gegen fährt also werde ich jetzt einfach
mal abwarten bis gleichen auto kommt und
dann diese formel 1 star jetzt komplett
dagegen
wir schauen uns das ganze jetzt mal in
der first person kamera an und zu sehen
wie so ein formel 1 unfall aussieht
ich glaube es tut weh das nächste level
was wir haben werde ich einfach mal hier
in so motorcross quad-bike versuchen zu
machen und wir haben da hinten sogar
eine brücke ich klicke einfach mal auf
go und hoffe dass luca das irgendwie es
war knapp 1 versucht jedes super noch
allerdings wichen kommen 1 wagen sondern
mit einer abrissbirne super gemacht
haben jetzt hat luca sogar einen space
weiter und damit sollte es doch jetzt
irgendwie möglich sein dass also das
überrascht mich immer wieder wie toll
diese jobs wirklich sind enttäuscht mich
nicht formel-1-wagen geschafft das in
die hose des moment lugt an dieser
stelle beendet mit wir erinnern wenn
euch das video und das spiel namens
turbo des mount gefällt und ihr noch
einen zweiten mal haben wollte weil es
gibt noch 1000 vehikels und 1000
verschiedene posen 1000 levels dann
zeigt es mir mit einer bewertung
schreibt mit vielleicht tipps in die
kommentare und dann werde ich nächste
woche noch mal ein paar hochladen bei
mir hat so viel spaß gemacht die feier
das spiel man kann es gut zusammen
schneiden
kauft man word